[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the american science fiction
film called voyagers spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts out in the year 2063
a.d human existence is at risk of
extinction because of climate change
decreasing biodiversity and decreasing
supply of clean drinking water the
deteriorating situation of the earth has
been troubling scientists for a long
time
in such harsh conditions they work hard
to find a planet where humans can settle
on at the beginning of the movie the top
scientists and astronomers of the world
are in a conference meeting they have
finally found an earth-like exoplanet
far away in the galaxy and discuss how
they can colonize it an astrophysicist
who is presenting the idea says that
they will have to leave for the
exoplanet as soon as possible because
the voyage will take 86 years thus the
crew will have to reproduce on board and
only the third generation of humans who
board the ship will make it to the
exoplanet the scientists first problem
is to find 30 qualified crew members who
are willing to leave everyone they know
on earth to spend the rest of their
lives on a spaceship moreover they have
to ensure that no one feels the stress
of prolonged confinement because then
they would want to return to the earth
the only solution to this problem is to
breed their own crew members and train
them in isolation that way the crew
members wouldn't know how the earth was
and wouldn't feel nostalgic so the
scientists use bioengineering to give
birth to 30 babies who will in the
future initiate the 86 year long voyage
to the exoplanet the kids are raised and
trained by a scientist named richard
alling richard treats the kids as his
own and with time grows attached to them
after a few years he insists on joining
them on their trip to space his
colleague warns that he will never be
able to return but richard claps back by
saying he's a scientist dammit and he
knows that he is adamant about the
decision eventually when the kids are of
a certain age they fly to outer space
with richard as their guardian the ship
will be their home for the rest of their
lives
cue to some years later the kids have
grown into youngsters and are perfectly
accustomed to their lives in space they
wake up every day at the same time and
take educational classes that tell them
of their purpose then they exercise and
do a regular mechanical check after that
they eat together in the cafeteria
throughout all this the crew seems void
of human emotions as they do not chat
with each other often an important part
of their day is taking a blue liquid
after every meal in the following scene
we see two crew members named chris and
zack listening to classical music as a
recreational activity another member
named sela is having doubts about the
mission and thinks of her life as
unimportant so she talks to richard
about it richard calmly explains that
they are the most important humans in
history he reveals he has been feeling
lonely for a long time and shows sila
pictures of his family from the earth
the crew grows its own plant to sustain
life for the years that they will be on
the ship one day chris discovers that
there is a toxin named t56j in the water
they irrigate the plants with the water
is filtered urine which means that the
toxin is coming from the crew's body he
asks richard about the toxin but he
simply tells chris to change the
filtration system later chris does some
research on the toxin but finds no
information about it in the database he
even tells zack about the matter after
everyone is asleep at night the two hack
into the database and find out that the
toxin comes from the blue liquid they
drink every day they also reveal that
the toxin makes humans docile eliminates
sexual desires and decreases pleasure
response that means the crew is being
drugged so they can be kept in check
from the following day zack and chris
stop taking the blue liquid they also
tell two of the other crew members named
kai and julie about their discovery
moreover chris has also found an
unmarked compartment in the ship behind
the walls the four of them have begun to
doubt their creators during a routine
conversation with richard chris tells
him that he has discovered an
unidentified chamber in the blueprints
and demands to know its purpose and what
exactly is inside of it richard proceeds
to evasively tell him that such
information is classified and that the
chamber is reserved for the third
generation on board the following day
chris and zack go through the emotions
that they have never felt in their lives
before being off the blue liquid is like
being on drugs for them it's like
they're speedrunning puberty zack feels
sexually attracted to sela and grabs her
arm he lets go of her only after richard
casually tells him to maintain distance
during their workout zack and chris play
fight feeling the rush of adrenaline for
the first time sometime later the two
are in the hallways when they hear
strange noises from the ship's ceiling
they go to the control room and ask
crewmate edward about it richard has
told them that it is just the noise of
the ship's parts contracting but edward
believes that the noise is caused by
some extraterrestrial creature after a
while richard holds an emergency meeting
informing the crew that they have lost
contact with the earth because of some
lct malfunction they will have to repair
the transmitter from outside of the ship
richard asks zack to join him and
assigns everyone their respective roles
as they prepare zack starts touching
selah inappropriately a surprise richard
stops him tells zach to stop simping and
asks sela if she is fine
zack runs away from them and richard
goes behind him a girl named phoebe
informs richard that zack has stopped
taking the blue liquid richard then
meets chris who reveals that he hasn't
been taking it either the two decide to
complete the reparation first then talk
about the matter they get into their
spacesuits and go outside meanwhile kai
from the navigation room helps them as
the others are in the control room doing
the same kai is soon joined by zack all
of a sudden richard's suit malfunctions
and electrocutes him at the same time
the whole ship malfunctions making the
crew panic the system's room catches on
fire while every technical difficulty
arises at the same time the crew put the
fire out while chris somehow manages to
get richard inside the ship they
hurriedly take him to the med bay and
use a defibrillator on him however it
doesn't work and richard dies
selah being the chief medical
professional sadly pronounces him dead
after everything calms down the crew
surrounds richard's body and discusses
what went wrong edward says that he saw
something dark pull richard right before
his death he thinks it was an alien
chris assures everyone that it was
outside the ship so they should be fine
zach volunteers to be the new chief
officer replacing richard but everyone
else decides they should vote the voting
takes place and eventually chris is
elected as the chief officer he then
orders everyone to repair the damage
that was caused to the ship as soon as
possible the crew gets to work and sela
goes to richard's room to get rid of his
belongings as per protocol however she
begins to watch pictures and videos of
his family and decides to keep them
christopher joins her and the two watch
the video documentary that richard had
made in the video he says that he came
to the mission because he wanted to
protect the kids the two are confused as
to what they need protection from but
little do they know what is about to
happen next a while later chris goes to
check on the crew's progress and sees no
one around he finds everyone in the
plantation area trying to fix the food
storage zach had brought them there
saying that food should be their first
priority and they shouldn't let it go
bad chris agrees and lets them do what
they want after dinner that day kai
tells everyone not to drink the blue
fluid the following day the crew feels
various emotions at the same time that
they cannot control their anger and
desires are heightened zack and julie
touch each other feeling attracted to
the opposite sex for the first time
others fight run around the ship and
ignore all their duties one day they get
into richard's room and watch films in
his collection from those they find out
about violence guns and sexual
intercourse sela finds them in the room
and orders them to get out as the chief
medical officer on his way out zach
threatens sela asking her to be careful
because richard isn't there to protect
her anymore later that day chris sees
kai and julie having intercourse in the
exercise room he also notices zach
looking for sela and runs to her before
he can he hugs her to show zach she is
already busy at the same time kai finds
a guy named peter and julie getting
close enraged with jealousy he attacks
peter making him run away later everyone
is at the cafeteria when peter hits kai
with a metal tool to take revenge chris
and the others separate the fight and
schedule an emergency meeting in the
control room in the meeting chris puts
forward his dissatisfaction regarding
the crew's performance but zack
interrupts him frequently edward says
that he doesn't want to work in the
control room anymore because he thinks
it has aliens brought by richard from
when he last spacewalked this scares
everyone as they too have been hearing
the noises taking this opportunity zack
says that he will save the crew from the
aliens and provide them with a lot of
food he also declares that he is forming
a separate group from chris and people
on his side can follow him half of the
crew leaves with zack while the other
half stays with chris chris's group is
also worried that the alien might be
real so they go to collect the
surveillance footage from the system's
room after they leave zach's team
arrives there and kai and he go inside
they act like an alien attacked them in
the room to scare the group and keep
them submissive meanwhile chris and the
group watch the surveillance footage and
find a clip of zack and kai deliberately
electrocuting richard they are beyond
surprised when they find that the two
killed richard the following morning
they are woken up by a knock on the door
zack and his group are there to invite
them for lunch chris and the team
carefully come to the cafeteria and
start to eat just then zack walks in
front of everyone and declares himself
the new chief officer but chris
retaliates and shows everyone the clip
of zack and kai killing richard everyone
gets up in surprise but to their
confusion zack admits to killing him he
says that he had seen an alien attach
itself to richard and had to kill him to
kill the alien he then says that the
alien might have attached itself to
someone else from the crew the naive
crew believes him and everyone gets real
suss all of a sudden with no evidence
they blame peter for carrying the alien
and beat him to death
after that they collect all the sharp
weapons to fight the alien if it is
still in the ship zack's team is
skeptical but they are afraid to speak
against him meanwhile on chris's team
sila suggests that they get the weapons
from the secret compartment that chris
knows about in the following scene we
see chris trying to open the secret
compartment behind the wall but he gets
the passcode wrong making an alarm go
off he runs away from the compartment
and zach's team arrives there they get
their hands on the weapons and claim
them as their own two of chris's
teammates decide to join zack zack asks
them for the other's location in turn
for taking them in and they happily tell
him where the others are now his team
approaches chris sela and phoebe in the
surveillance room they barge inside and
hold chris hostage before they can take
him away phoebe loses control and yells
at everyone to come back to their senses
to everyone's surprise an annoyed zack
shoots her dead knowing that they are
next chris and sela run away from the
others they are soon followed by the
group after a while zack finds them and
chases them into the airlock with a gun
in his hand now with no way out chris
quickly thinks of a plan he and sela put
on space suits and open the hatch so
when zack barges in he is pulled into
space sila and chris return to the rest
of the group who have become docile
without their leader the scene changes
to some days later when everything has
gone back to normal after an election
sela is chosen as the new chief she
keeps a video documentary as richard did
in the documentary she reveals that they
have decided not to take the blue liquid
again but they will vote on everything
so no further conflicts arise wait until
they get older and realize that voting
solves nothing a few weeks after the
restoration of democracy and peace sela
finds out that she is pregnant with
chris's child and eventually gives birth
to a boy things seem to have changed
back to normal and everyone on the ship
is happy for the next few decades kids
run around the ship playing and learning
about their duties while the elders take
care of them and teach them their true
purpose and finally after 86 years since
the launch the ship is about to land on
the destination planet the movie ends as
the old and new generation watch them
getting closer to their new home
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thanks for watching